over the last hour we've heard the very
beginnings of the prosecution case
against Thomas Cashman the 34 year old
accused of murdering murdering Olivia
Pratt Corbell who was shot and died in
her own home in August last year and in
very broad brush Strokes for now the
prosecution have outlined the timeline
of events as they say they happened they
say that Thomas Cashman intended to kill
Joseph knee and on that night in August
in Liverpool last year Joseph knee was
at a friend's house watching a football
game Liverpool versus Manchester United
and that after the conclusion of that
game he left his friend's home with
another friend and then as he was
leaving the prosecutions say that Thomas
Cashman approached them running fast the
prosecution Barrister Campbell
McLaughlin Casey saying it was clear
that the man we believe was Thomas
Cashman mint business and it wasn't good
business the jury were then shown freeze
frames from CCTV footage on the road
where Olivia Pratt called Bell lived
they outlined a man they say was Thomas
Cashman following Joseph knee they said
as I say running fast and then in moving
footage the jury was shown 15 seconds of
a man the prosecution as I say they say
was Thomas Cashman shooting Joseph knee
three shots were fired on the road close
to Olivia Pratt corbell's house and it's
at that point the prosecution say that
Olivia's mother Cheryl Corbell opened
the door to her home to see what was
going on at Joseph knee the prosecution
said perhaps seeing a glimmer of light
approached that door and Thomas Cashman
followed him they say he was relentless
in his pursuit of Joseph the prosecution
say referring to Thomas Cashman and then
firing shots continuing to fire shots at
Joseph knee one of those shots traveled
through the front door of Cheryl Corbell
the prosecution told the jury traveling
through the door through Cheryl core
Bell's hand injuring her and then
hitting Olivia Pratt Corbell in the
chest that was the shot that later she
would die from in hospital
the prosecution say this is what this
case is all about they say it is about
the ruthless Pursuit by Thomas Cashman
to shoot Joseph knee at all costs
without any consideration for anyone
else in the community the case here is
expected to last at least four weeks
with this broad prosecution opening
outlined in Fuller detail Thomas Cashman
denying all the charges against him that
one of attempted murder of Olivia Pratt
Corbell the attempted murder of Jews
Joseph knee the malicious wounding of
Cheryl Corbell and two counts of
possessions of an illegal firearm all of
those charges Thomas Cashman 34 pleading
not guilty to